this is Startalk and I'm your host Neil
deGrasse Tyson your personal
astrophysicist and we are coming to you
from my office at the Hayden Planetarium
of the American Museum of Natural
History right here in New York City and
today I have a special guest and he's
gonna be my only guest for this hour we
don't do that on it's only if everything
clicks and all cylinders are in place
I've got with me one and only Jordan
Klepper Jordan yes welcome to Startalk
your first time is my first time thanks
for having me a lot of pressure
excellent the only one here I'm not
saying there's no pressure
yeah you're making it rain by not saying
that you're making a very clear okay we
can do this welcome you've got a show on
Comedy Central
you've been spawned from from The Daily
Show I'd like to think that I've run off
yes fun birth into the world yes just
through the through the the magic of Jon
Stewart for ever Noah yeah I work for
both yes and they pushed me now through
there they're they're lovely comedy
cavity into the world through their
birth canal yes yes yes their birth
canal there you go
you got a show you you command the whole
hour with very high production values
you're going around the world
yeah subjecting yourself to different
things interviewing people and in
particular the reason why we noticed you
recently is because we saw that you've
got a show on the space program yeah and
so I will get to that in a minute okay
okay I just don't want you to think we
would have asked you on here for any old
reason you just like we did a lot of
other episodes that we don't care you in
my mind this was for you I knew it I
know I did six episodes like Neil is not
gonna be in any of these you need one of
them just let's give him some space
to pop through here I just want to look
at your background here you you had a
double major in math and theater whoo
yeah how did how does that work
boy I tell you I I saw I went to where
was this this is in Kalamazoo Michigan
Kalamazoo I was just in Kalamazoo you
and Kalamazoo just like a few weeks ago
who are you doing
I'm also part host as well okay okay
whoa whoa Jordan thank you
well first did you know that our very
own Derek Jeter was raised in Kalamazoo
Michigan you know as somebody who grew
up in Kalamazoo I of course knew that
because I've lived in the show just
judges do we the shadow of Derek Jeter
it's a long shadow yeah he would he went
to my high school just before I did and
the endure Jeter was he was a hero I
knew his sister Sharlee and everybody
thought Derek Jeter he was such a good
athlete he was going to be a
professional basketball player
basketball player he was great at
basketball we make more money in
baseball you play more games and all the
money's the money comes out he knew that
I didn't play the sport longer - exactly
yeah I think he made the right choice
I think we're not the best
prognosticators I grew up there I went
to a place called the nerd farm which is
the math and science center which means
you go to a special math and science by
so that's why I say it's nice yeah this
is right your other friends I might have
said what's wrong with you dude this was
the Joe Rogan podcast I'd be talking
about my public school for the other
half of the day for you Neal I'm talking
about the nerd the nerd so what happened
so you're in school they notice you have
a little geek in you I got so they put
you in the nerd farm they put you in the
nerd farm if you got a little geek they
got they got special facilities for the
geeks you focus on math you focus on
science you spent four years doing that
for half the school then for the other
half you go to the public school well so
they nurture this a nerd very very
enlightened system yeah cam which is
really proud of it the math and science
center it's and students go in all
different directions afterwards but it's
sort of a chance for people to to to
kind of indulge the geeky side I gave a
public talk in Kalamazoo in a for city
tour of Michigan gently yeah yeah it's a
great town yeah I love that it was it
was fun very friendly people and sort of
unpretentious just people just want to
be themselves and want to learn they're
their kind of folk the motto in
Kalamazoo is yes there really is a
Kalamazoo I love it's already defends
because it's already like what are you
from Kalamazoo it's not even real you
know what is real yes there really is a
Kalamazoo it's
gonk windward ok that's what I figured
yeah you're already defensive when you
come from Kalamazoo so the theater part
how did that fit in well so I got a
scholarship that paid for my college if
I studied math and I did and I will say
I was a smart kid but when your math
moving the judge of it well you will be
on TV day if you edit this correctly I'm
a smart kid yeah I found I love math I
think my mind I liked my mind I love
solving problems I love the process of
man but I also realized within that that
many people think math is getting the
answer right but it's not it's the
process the journey to the answer and I
would say like what I ended up finding
while I was doing math was I think I
enjoyed the performative elements as
well I started finding informative
elements of math calculate digits of pi
while I danced while I was doing math
that was doing improv and comedy as well
and so that became surely as high
schooler was at Collin College on the
improv team in college nice and college
works Kalamazoo College how was your
college it's a little liberal arts
college right smack dab in the in the
middle of Kalamazoo improv world popped
up but I was like I think I want to I
want to play around in that and it was
full of discovery people laughed at the
things I said occasionally there's not a
ton of laughter or applause in the math
class but algebra doesn't have many
standing ovations never standing
ovations it turns out I was so needy
that I was like I'm gonna follow the
thing that gives me a standing ovation I
will say as much as like I went to the
world of comedy the world of math what
it is true it's it's a way of thinking
it's about process and then I kind of go
into the world of comedy where you start
writing sketch comedy start doing improv
but in the world of like sketch comedy
and writing there's a process there as
well and I think like that kind of
mathematical brain can can help an
artist or a person in that world try to
figure out ways in which they can move
an audience to an understanding of what
a joke yeah you become analytical in it
and I think that has value and not
everything is intuitive fact maybe the
best is a combination of both I
certainly get you
going with the with the stereotype of
now you got both brain halves
you know tickled I think that's I've
always seen to like there's even there's
the two brain halves yeah yeah I don't
know if that's held up you know in in
neuroscience analysis but it's a nice
metaphor for thinking about two ways of
approaching the world I think like
stand-ups definitely approach things
from an analytical perspective and I'm
more of an improviser which is more like
the creative let's go search and find
yeah I think ultimately when you start
working you want a little bit of both
you can you can search but eventually
you have to figure out why things work
and then put it down on paper and then
sell it and see if Coke will by
advertisements so so this is a sort of
obvious question but maybe not for it
for for some people you the the
portfolio of shows you've been doing now
on Comedy Central what's the name of
your show
clapper why don't I remember the name of
his show so I should just ask him a
handful of shows and now we're just like
you know what they're gonna call it's
that guy guys show just call it the
clever show now there's there's good
precedent there's the Andy Griffith Show
yes and the Mary Tyler Moore Mary Tyler
Moore and that they don't save anything
but the show is about it's just a
people's name it's the Mary Tyler Moore
Show and I think I'd like to think I'm
the Frazier of political satire
okay so you've you've tackled some very
disturbing topics so how what's your
formula for making them funny good
question would you wait for a moment
where there's a silly or fun element but
at the end you're very socially
progressive and what you're trying to
get people to do and which aren't to get
into thing and some of these topics are
very sad they are I think when we
started out doing the show it's
essentially a doc series documentary
series on Comedy Central which doesn't
usually do these types of things right
and we wanted to pick topics that were
important that I cared about that my
staff cared about that we thought needed
more attention and
one of you were in the Bayou I was in
the Bayou I follow the time what was the
title that was so that one was battling
the Bayou which was a group of
environmentalists who are locking
themselves to pipelines to try to stop
the the pipeline from moving through the
Bayou or get killed or get killed okay
so it was this was sort of a chance for
us to see what environmentalist and by
environmentalism looks like up close in
the trenches let's get in the trenches
get in the boat that boat ended up
sinking is what I found out 5:00 a.m. in
the Bayou a boat or their boat my boat I
went out with them they were going to
the Bayou they were going to lock
themselves up to this pipeline and as we
go you were your conservative worm who
got in there and saying don't don't blow
this for me all right
idiotic comedian / conservative spy okay
yeah we found ourselves in the Bayou we
go up very deep I don't think it's wide
though I you know they said there were
alligators down there we saw them on the
way and we we go by the site and there's
a security boat that's there that starts
to follow us and they turn into the wake
we take on a ton of water and we
suddenly find ourselves swimming to the
shoreline
whoa so you get you get wet do it a
docu-series hmm and I think to go back
to the idea of where the humor is like
the humor is you didn't get eaten the
humors you don't get any we put me in a
dangerous situation
okay the audience is gonna feel bad for
me they're gonna see me complain about
how hard it is to enact real change and
I become the conduit of difficulty okay
and that that's always good fodder
we followed veterans who are like who's
suffering from PTSD and I think what you
found a different episode that's a
different episode that one called that
one's called wrestling with PTSD they do
it through literally professional
wrestling and so they found like a
creative way to deal with an actual
problem might get in the ring I become a
part of it and I think like the humor
comes through me trying but did you wear
a singlet a wrestling singlet I wish it
were as as forgiving as a singlet
what do you call half a thing that I
it's like the speedo you shouldn't be
wearing in my in the 21st century Neil
what is the scientific term for banana
hammock all I know I think what I saw it
ads is unflattering I wore something
that did not flatter off what God or the
universe gave me more your actual
musculature that could otherwise be
flattering in a different outfit they
hired me for my brains not my body so
how did that play out I mean did you did
you help help people recover so the fact
that that you get to air their story I
mean I think like part of it is shining
light on people who are actually taking
action I think you know joking aside
I've gotten to work on some great shows
where you're in New York and talking
about what's happening out in America
this was a chance to really I want to go
out and see people who are doing stuff
day in and day out and we're in our own
bubble here we're in a bubble City we're
in a bubble it's a big bubble but it's
still a bubble it's a bubble and I think
like I went to Georgia and they're a
bunch of students who are daca students
and documented students who just want to
go to college and they're protesting
they're trying to get their voice out
and so I think like it's you get
arrested I got arrested standing up with
those students so yeah I mean these are
the links Comedy Central makes you go
and they let you out they let me have
you seen my body of work 12 hours later
after some coughing just make sure
you're not a contraband smuggling they
let you out of jail ok that happens I
think you know you're hopefully moving
the needle by bringing attention to it
and I don't want to pretend like me
being down there for a week with people
is going to be the thing that changes
everything but hopefully through a
little levity and point of view I can
show like but there are people doing
good things there are people who are
fighting and I think like even if I fail
with some of that fight we should we
should take a little inspiration when
the people are pushing something forward
so what you're really saying is if the
show ever gets cancelled the ones you've
completed are still an important
contribution to the television
repertoire no I'm not saying that you
just said that I'm gonna type it out I'm
gonna put it on my gravestone I
appreciate that
no you can be proud of it I mean it's a
you know who and by the what at least in
New York it's
11:30 mm-hm either what's up with that
well because the good old daily show
takes place right before 11:30 p.m.
oh so you want to run in so and in this
world okay their work you're not viewer
they're like oh and this tends to appeal
to people who are politically engaged
interested and maybe a little bit stoned
at 11:30 at night and now I'm older than
you so you may not remember this the
origin of ABC's Nightline was was 11:30
that was a lot whatever came on yes
there is a there is an origin for it you
know it has an origin story what's the
urgency the origin story is it started
out as the nightly updates on the
hostage crisis in Iran day forty day a
hundred and fifty day this and then they
got all this all this audience that it
just bursts the show and what they were
doing is they give the final news story
in the in the Evening News and that
would take you right in to this new
program that was birth simply because of
Iran coverage is that right that's what
that is
it's so one what the evening news fed
the the follow-ups or show and that
became its own thing I'd like to think
people are tuning into my show with the
the daily hostage crisis that is
American political system we're all beat
we all feel like we're being held
hostage just see if this guy someone
hostage yes yes Broadway now is the
network yeah with Bryan Cranston can you
give really its you seen it you got to
know somebody now you yeah I did see I
was unlike the third row it's great oh
not yet Robin in it yeah he was he was
extraordinary and he won the Tony Award
for that and guess what Jordan what it
closed wow that's wow to rub it in some
more man who likes to focus he can't I
mean the show was his performance you
don't have to share every fact you know
some facts are best left unsaid like
that one oh that was I did learn that
from some wise people they said just
because it's true doesn't mean it has to
be said that's who that is a lovely
phrase yeah yeah yeah I've dude some
government people I worked with Oh hobo
the government political types so so all
truths don't always have to be
what you lead with let it be true but
not advertised I think doesn't mean you
want to hide it you just don't want to
display it that's all
I've I've had a marriage counselor who
said the same thing there's another I
related to that is occasionally
stretching the truth or ignoring one or
two bad things is the right thing to do
such as when you're speaking at funerals
there are times when just let this one
go would you say now from a scientific
mindset things like climate change
things that feel like perilous
situations that people are maybe failing
to grass no those aren't the truth I'm
talking about right right
truth about a person when it comes to
science your science no I'm all-in
you're straight-laced okay give me a
free pass here so one of your shows
which is why we invited you to start
talk at all not that we don't love you
would you it's all about the space
program nicely timed with the
anniversary the 50th anniversary of
Apollo 11 landing on the moon I'm across
so I want to spend the rest of our time
together talking about your experience
there and then we'll compare notes a
little bit I know but I didn't get all
in up in it the way you did oh that's
what I do I put on the suits all up in
it
so in Startalk returns more of my
exclusive interview with jordan klepper
we're back on Startalk neil degrasse
tyson I'm here with Jordan Klepper you
surely know him from Comedy Central if
you don't you should because he's got a
new show on Comedy Central where he goes
around the world investigating topics
that we all care about or all should
care about and he does it in a very
hands-on involved way very different
from seeing him behind the desk making
comedic quips at stories that other
people bring you did do a few on
location stories for comedy sir I did
yes when I was enjoying what you went to
the when you went to the conventions and
things those were fun a lot of field
pieces for the Daily Show as of
corresponding you're out in the field a
bunch this was sort of an extension of
that get me out there okay excellent and
we've got you on the show because you
explored our space program and first
first what motivated you second is there
some overriding social cultural issue
that you wanted to tear apart not to
destroy but to unpack no I just like
space okay excellent it's a mix of two
things honestly I will say this you're
not just saying that I know I because
there's a Saturn 5 rocket behind you
yeah yeah yeah there goes this would be
the room to definitely give some lip
service to security to remove you
otherwise in the Hayden Planetarium it
does feel like perhaps this is the type
of talk about this is the time so it's
two things I've been a little bit of a
space nerd since I was a kid I would go
to two places when I was a kid my
parents would take me into Washington DC
or Cape Canaveral and so you can never
win Florida yes and so I you know I I
fell in love with the idea becoming an
astronaut is I think a lot of people do
my kids a lot of kids do yes I think
I've gotten to indulge that throughout
my life um back when I was hosting the
show called the opposition we had Scott
Kelly on astronaut scott kelly who spent
over 500 days you see the good looking
one of the twins he's a hot twin the hot
twins mark Mark Kelly is the the ugly
twin running for Senate Scott's the sexy
sexy twin I love them both we've had
we've had Scott Kelly on here it's what
Scott or was it more
Scott yeah yeah we have one of the twins
yeah yeah the sexy one we had the we
have
I went into space yes yeah the one who
agrees to do the show they get to be the
sexy one that's what I've always said
Lister Scott Kelly came on the show
which people don't remember because he's
a twin it became of by high
physiological and biological interest
just send one into space for an extended
length of time leave the other one here
on earth and then they come back and
compare them and according to relativity
the one into space came back a little
younger and then the other one by the
way yes but not not by very much but you
can calculate it and squishier right
well that's that's for different reasons
yeah it's not like space made him
Squishy well I mean being in space made
him squish I don't know if rotating
space stations that had artificial
gravity he wouldn't be squishy so that's
what it is
well there could be other reasons but
that's the main one but I want to get to
the bottom of my squishy I'm a squishy
denier let me be very honest with you
nail I've been a squishy deniers as I
was okay that's my trainer you know
where's my six-pack and he said it's in
there just under the fat okay good we
just need gyms that are rotating at a
certain speed that allow us squishy men
to become less squishy exactly Kelly on
this show talk about important things
like squishiness on your show or but I
might look back in the on the opposition
he was a guest on the show
I remember the opposition yes and so
that was between that when you left
comedy all right that was between when
you left the Daily Show in 2017 and your
current contribution exactly yep it was
a late-night show had a lot of
fascinating people on and talking to
Scott backstage he was talking a lot
about the right stuff and how that was a
movie in the book exactly now he read
the book when he was a kid and inspired
him to want to be an astronaut to want
to engage in science again and it got me
thinking it was like oh you know I had
such a fun time you know jumping back in
and talking about space with Scott Kelly
I'm gonna read the right stuff there's
about a year ago I read the right stuff
and I became obnoxious with all of my
friends for the following four months
just say you have to read this it's
amazing I just I was realized with the
space program when all the documentaries
coming out about the Apollo 11 mission
it was one of these things that suddenly
just lit up in me and we're trying to
look for stories and I was I'd come in
and I'd tell my life that's made every
since we're talking much space it didn't
light up and
you it ignited ooh yes thank you it may
help your vocabulary yes it did there's
a spark that ignited knighted and then
blast off I was back in it I was
pitching stories in our allows me to
edit your your your personal commentary
if you can make me a little bit smarter
and more clever throughout I will take
it go so I'm as we're pitching stories
I'm consistently referencing how much I
liked the movie first man how much I
liked the rice man the profile of new
Armstrong exactly I thought it was such
an interesting human way that to me they
even the process to gating the moon in
and of itself felt like such a difficult
and lonely process that I thought a
movie like that was able to capture and
as we're pitching these things my staff
is like why don't we just do an episode
on space for God's sakes you can't stop
talking about that you're trying to get
you to shut up they're trying to get me
to shut up right which any good staff
will do you know of course and at the
same time what we were talking about
like I have somebody who's progressive
and on the left side of the aisle who's
often very critical of our commander in
chief and at the same time President
Donald Trump is talking a lot about the
space program he's making outlandish
claims like that you made the comment is
like what will it take to get us to Mars
if I give you unlimited money could we
get there before the next election which
is a ludicrous claim but in that moment
it lined up somewhat with my instinct of
like oh yeah we need to dream big this
idea of dreaming for that moonshot slash
Marsha that's something that I feel is
missing it was when I look back at the
the Apollo 11 I look back the Apollo
program in general at least through
rose-colored glasses you hear of a time
where people were coming together
they're investing in science they were
trying to do things that felt impossible
and through doing that there are a lot
of benefits to our society and there was
a lot of cultural cohesion with some
caveats for sure but there was a
positivity there that felt like was
lacking and we actually have a commander
in chief who I don't agree with on
almost anything but is sort of like hey
I think we can get to Mars I'm like you
sound crazy but in this case I like it
so we look to do an episode of like what
does the fight look like to get to Mars
is that the kind of thing are we going
to make America great again with a big
asterisk but are we going to like go
back to what was
Niq and interesting about the apollo 11
mission is that something that's in
store for American is that something
that's good for America this is why I
didn't interrupt you is because I have
nothing to add or subtract from what you
just said
Thank You Neil not that other times when
I interrupt you I do yes really make me
look back on the rest of all the rest of
the interviews no so firstly yes it is
absurd to imagine that we would land on
Mars before the next election but it's
not absurd to imagine that we would have
a Mars program ready to happen before
the next election and if anyone else
thinks it's absurd you have to ask is it
crazy for a president to say I want to
start getting to Mars and before the end
of my next term I want to have landed on
Mars so I get to make the phone call I
don't know that President Trump said
that but he's surely thinking and right
so is that a crazy thing here's my
question to you is getting to Mars in
six years more crazy than getting to the
moon in seven mmm-hmm
President Kennedy's speech where we're
gonna go to the moon but do it with in
1962 no excuse me 61 hit several
speeches in 1961 we didn't have a ship
that could launch a human being that
wouldn't explode on the launch pad we
didn't yet have that spacecraft and he
says we're gonna put a man on the moon
before the decade is out and we do it
within eight years so to go from an
impossible dream
to an accomplished dream that's got to
be more remote than anything any sitting
president can say today that they want
to happen have happened in the next six
years that's all I'm saying 100% agree
yeah I I think that's what it is I have
a crazy you want to say Trump is just be
level head as a scientist I'm try to be
level-headed about all this same with
Trump space force Trump said space for
us thereby said no not we got problems
on earth what anybody want to have words
with people just just react
without pausing and thinking on what
well let's think about this otherwise
you're just aligning yourself with
political whims and not using your own
brain to analyze a statement made by one
side of the aisle or the other mm-hmm
so I think it's a very I think it's a
very compelling question that it that a
person who is is a radioactive when it
comes to politics but it would take
somebody in a position like that to set
the bar that high and then trust that
people pulling together could
potentially get there I think like we're
in a time where I'm hearing a lot of
people talking about climate change in
order to stop the effects of climate
change we would need the type of effort
it took during World War Two to come
together I was just in Detroit this past
weekend and I was looking at the
architecture of Detroit and some of
these buildings that were built that are
stunning gorgeous stunning the Fisher
Building I was in a monument to American
ingenuity was built in 13 months and
it's it's unbelievable and in world war
ii we were building battleships right
here in the Brooklyn Navy aren't just
just pumping them out when we agree that
hey this is something we're going to do
now all its terms aligned all Pistons
aligned let's get these things done and
I think thank-yous me that's an internal
combustion engine reference all gears
are in place thank you all for the
electric motor yeah all panels have been
loaded two solar panels are tracking the
Sun at all angles in the sky now I'm
lost this we're never gonna get to Mars
this what it is we're not gonna be able
to contextualise it away there's gonna
get us on the same page I'll work on it
there's there's something really
evocative one about grandiose thinking
two about scientific exploration in a
way that is on a level that that is is
beyond what people can imagine and I
think like some of that comes with a
time period where people are afraid I
think wanting to beat the Russians was a
big part of the 60s not wanting to die
yes not money did I that works every
character stick person that's a good
stick not wanting to die and so I think
like I think it's a compelling question
right now it shouldn't just be thrown
out baby with the bathwater of like can
we get to Mars sure that sounds
ludicrous is that a main question in in
in the episode because as of the
recording it hasn't aired yet yep the
thing that kicks us off is I don't agree
with the president on many things but
this is actually something that connects
with me of like is this something that
is gonna be realistic in our lifetime
and what is that what is that going to
take
and so we accept that as like alright
let's go talk to some people we go and
we talked to Scott Kelly to hear he's
been up there he has some opinions what
he thinks I go to a Mars habitat and
Hawaii to see what some of the training
would look like was that you know naa I
don't know the Hawaii one I know of one
in in Canada yes yes there's one on the
Big Island on the volcanic mountain man
Aloha they're all volcanic just that's
how they rose from the bottom of the
ocean all right you okay that's what an
archipelago is you know what that is
it's a hot spot underneath Earth's
moving crust okay and it's just sitting
there and the crust is there and punches
through makes a volcano then it goes
dormant the crust keeps moving then it
punches through again part pauses it
keeps moving punches through again so
it's a string of volcanic island
archipelago essentially is a volcanic
series as I understand it my my
rudimentary geology that's correct
how many islands does it take to be an
archipelago is there like a flat line I
more than one for sure I don't know but
go on so I went to mount Aloha which
there's a place called high seas which
is a Mars habitat that is actually
treated also into a moon habitat because
it's got the volcanic terrain they have
a volcanic terrain it is incredibly
remote the NASA had paid for this site
now it's privately owned and the
European the internationally European
Space Agency was was sending potentially
so that's European Space Agency s they
were sending people over actually and as
we were leaving there that's a long way
from Europe
dude that's a hike that's like you might
as well just dig a hole through the
earth and go through yeah yeah well and
at that point if you're living in London
with the rain you're like I'll go to
Hawaii okay so we spent some time I
spent some time on the the top of mount
Aloha and of talking to them about not
only what it would what life I mean the
people who were the people whose habitat
exactly I'll be sneaking in Cheetos or
something are they
you know let's say they what they aren't
but I I think there's something just
something looking there orange finger
he's got it so yeah this I know they
sneaked him something in Cheetos are not
naturally occurring on the Martian
landscape know this for a spite of the
red color licking off their fingertips I
mean a lot of what they're testing right
there is just the psychological
challenges of living on Mars for an
extended period of time
not only the possible two years there
and back what it's like just live in a
small enclosed space with people and
what sort of funny as as a layperson but
also as a as an improviser it's somebody
who's taught improv that's all about
group dynamics it's about how you can
teach people how to listen how not to
kill one another how to build off of
ideas and so a lot of the things they
were training for and studying up there
were the type of things that are our
basic human community isn't that already
fully researched just with families at
Thanksgiving know what getting a group
of people who know each other really
well what happened when they got to sit
down together the problem we haven't
recorded you know and we have it written
down no one is recording their own
Thanksgiving we just talk about it the
next morning the water cooler nobody's
ready we got to put pen to paper guys oh
man this is you could do scientific
research every Thanksgiving look one
thing I'll add to that before we take
our next break is again I'm old enough
to remember a lot of the Twilight Zone
episodes in real time and they were made
during the build-up of the space program
on the way to the moon
so space showed up in many of the topics
more as a philosophical thing not this
is really gonna happen this way they
just said if spaces of goal what are
some ramifications of this and multiple
episodes were about the loneliness of
space and how it could mess with your
head and I said Wow
and then I then when I got older I
realized there are times I don't want to
talk to anybody I'd be perfectly happy
spending a week give me a book a Netflix
account I'm fine I don't want to talk to
anybody and I'm I'm socialized imagine
the hermit's who are out there who could
go years doing this
then I realized that both that BS there
plenty of people who don't need human
contact for their own sanity a B every
astronaut in space is getting yakked at
by NASA all the time time to wake up
Mission Control you're here dude have
you done your thing there is no
loneliness in space yes I'm saying just
I wanna nip that in the bud
okay plus we're not sending one
astronaut anywhere right they didn't
know that at the time during the Mercury
program it was one astronaut but later
on it's a whole team of people so I'm
not I'm not buying this psychological
thing you know you can easily find seven
people who really just don't give a
perfectly happy staying there alone but
take those seven people who don't give a
who are good at being alone and put
them together buddy who's been married
for 50 years and get them to write their
journals and then just cue off of that
or probe that marriage send them up
there when we come back I just want to
get more detail from Jordan Klepper
about his episode on are we going to
Mars when stark talked interpreter
we're back star talk a singular episode
with one guest who's doubling as my
guest my co-host and my expert we don't
do this very often
we're flying close to the Sun you're
feeling you feeling that burn in his wax
wings are still are still holding on so
reference to Icarus in case they make
arrest for those people following at
home doesn't end well so tell me some of
the things you subjected yourself to so
I subject myself to a trip to Hawaii
which was mistake devastated that's just
so you know I'm such a tough guy I know
man you you you took one for the team in
the name of science send me back to
Hawaii so what what other than
subjecting yourself to a trip to Hawaii
what did you do so I centrifuge I did so
I I didn't do it out there so what I
ended up going to we spent some time in
Hawaii
one of your trips Hawaii and we habitat
Hawaii habitat Hawaiian we talked to
Hank Rogers who is a multi-millionaire
who's investing in that and in trying to
invest in space millionaires named Hank
blue collar that's a man that's a
practical guy I did a little date
drinking with Scott Kelly down in
Houston which was a day drinking with a
astronaut was right that's the thing
that's the thing day drinking and then I
wanted to go to what was the beverage it
was it's a drink called space dust
there's a there's a bar outside so far
it's classified yes okay go on there is
a bar outside of NASA in Houston where
all the astronauts go to which you know
we were gonna interview Scott we're
talking about let's just NASA's in a
community just look like a like a suburb
of Houston it is it is very much not in
Houston when I'm found out and when you
meet there we're like where do you meet
up he said well there's a bar all US
astronauts go to it in my mind I'd like
the right stuff and have these romantic
ideas it's like you're gonna walk in
there's gonna be Chuck Yeager in the
corner be badass unless you're spin
there's a tough guy spitting at a bar
yeah and you turn into this and what
makes this bar remarkable is it's the
closest bar to NASA it's efficient it's
yes these are all scientifically trained
people efficient it's the closed bar so
we'll go there there you go so we drink
the local IPA which is called space dust
we get a little we get a little boozy
and then I headed to Space Camp because
I want a few stores there others the one
in Huntsville Huntsville Alabama yes so
you got a hunt so has a standing
full-scale rocket model of the Saturn 5
it's unbelievable yeah it's like a
compass direction you know and there's
there's so much history there with the
how much of that was built in Huntsville
and I think like it does feel like such
a unique universe almost out of place
with so many other places that you
travel to Huntsville is an enclave
unlike anything else in all of Alabama
whoo very true it's highly educated
scientists engineers they have a good
school system and the rest of Alabama
not so much yes it's a unique little
spot it's another thing we were looking
at with this episode is
where is America's trajectory with our
potential mission tomorrow but before
you get to that yes I wanna know what
you subjected yourself to physically I
go into Space Camp and I got myself in
the spinning thing I got myself in the
centrifuge which is pretty thing is that
one that goes in all coordinates yeah
yeah it's the Leonardo da Vinci just
like the rugged man
looks I got it Space Camp retreat man is
butt-naked in the middle of the original
comedian the Vitruvian Man what when
also when I went in there well I
wouldn't I did a centrifuge which goes
up to 3 G's mm-hmm and I was doing it by
the way just FYI
3 G's is like where a good roller
coaster will take you yes I'm so doing
this to be the Rockets could accelerate
to higher than 3 G's they just don't
it's an interesting fact when they
launch from Earth there's all this fuel
and but is that the thrust is the same
it's constant and so there's a lot of
fuel as the fuel gets burned the rocket
weighs less so the same thrust will
actually accelerate it faster there's a
point where it could accelerate much
faster than 3d and they throttle back
just to not have you pinned against it
because they don't have to isn't
anything too has that always been the
case uh in the old days I don't know
just but recently that's that's how they
do it they throttle back so that you
don't experience much more than 3 G's
yes getting launched into space that's
why they pegged it of 3 G's also it's
Space Camp so I know there's primarily
children that are coming through and
forty-year-old satirical comedian it's a
weird cross-section so did you did you
barf up your lunch um I I did not I did
not barf I felt terrible the entire day
because you're kind of the adequate
stuff yeah I'm I quickly realized I'm
not going to space I won I'm too big and
tall - they didn't tell me if you're
about 6-4 6-4 yeah so so you felt queasy
that's why it's expect I felt queasy
each one my bod
was not made for it so what else they
make you do so then maybe if you make
yourself do what cuz they there's also
it's it's a they essentially have you
they run you through a simulation where
you attempt to fix the International
Space Station which they put you in a
sling to simulate zero gravity okay
which is just essentially you look like
a weird cow that's going to slaughter
they like lift you up your they place
you horizontal and then you just kind of
float around trying because you're not
actually weightless at that time you can
still swallow it goes down and yeah yeah
you still going up and down yes yeah if
you drop your pen it'll fall I don't
think is that is that incredibly no no
they didn't know initially if you know I
shouldn't have mentioned that at all
what do you know name huh what are you
hiding if I'm not authorized no no there
was in the early days we didn't know for
sure if you could swallow in space but
you can in Georgie yes but it turns out
you can do in space anything that you
can do upside down
is that right about that so you can
swallow upside down yeah and you can eat
upside down and that's gravity in the
complete opposite direction from right
side up which is just based on the
strength of your bottom of all of the
the valves and everything your you know
you can you can live not for long more
comfortably upside down your blood still
pumps you're so so that me and you can
do it horizontally so we do vertically
horizontally and upside down zero-g is
not a thing you're fine
yeah I know that was talking to Scott
Kelly and not to get too gross about it
but I asked him about using the restroom
the restroom yeah both of them and he
talked about like that is a definite
explain that is the first question of
twelve-year-old asks is that what a
scientist s the word is the first
scientist as do you yes question a
highly curious human being will ask
thank you and that includes children as
well as scientists yes exactly you pick
which one you want to question it might
not if you watch my show might also be
the second and third question they asked
yeah it's an interesting thing so do you
think based on everything you saw does
your show that episode of your show have
a conclusion I think the conclusion is
you know I'm optimistic about it from a
selfish point of view I do think it's
something that has potential I think
I am inspired by the idea of placing
that bar high and trying to achieve it
talking to people like Scott Kelly and
other folks on the ground there like it
feels like we're probably if it were
going to happen 12 to 15 years off who's
this person you interviewed that wants
to be the first so her name is Alyssa so
we found this person who's been training
to be an astronaut since she was 3 years
old literally has certifications from
here across the world has gone to Space
Camp I think 18 times Wow she's in an 18
year old girl who this has been her
dream and so we kind of wanted to talk
to somebody who was so much I send her
yeah we got a centre-right what did she
know she could die she does has talked
about part of it good she's even talked
about potentially removing like a
gallbladder or things that for a
potential Mars mission they would the
things that you might remove as a
contraceptive ly so that you know in
case you have like your appendix yes you
don't want your tenecia get inflamed
when no one can come to it yes so you
proactively remove prophylactically what
I say I said contraceptive services out
saying you can see but proactive I think
yes you probably find word today okay
let's do proactive nun
so she was discussing that I think what
was what I took away from that was I
wanted to talk to somebody who is of a
she called ourselves the March
generation
I remember what about the moon at all
their thickness not even there now it's
there's the moon might be the way in
which you did it'll stop there and then
go all the way to Mars but I think she
wants to she wants to be there she wants
to be the the Neil Armstrong of our
generation okay or their generation
perhaps is maybe more Neil Armstrong of
us all today there you are
we all get a Neil Armstrong yes I think
I'm up to mystic as far as that goes we
look a lot also at the private space
race and I think there's a money gonna
come from the course a trillion dollars
I mean I think that's where you're
looking at what's happening is nobody's
writing the check now go home yeah yeah
well I think but capitalism a thing
that's happened in America and always
has driven America I think
SpaceX Blue Origin those those types of
endeavors making us close I'm hoping I'm
skeptical only because if they're
business that you want to make money off
mm-hmm and how you making money off that
sent him the first mission there I don't
know
where's the return on that investment
well I won't you gonna charge people to
watch it mm-hmm you know like the
Olympics you're charging people that
means commercial time but maybe that's
what it'll take
well that's I mean honestly you talk
about American ingenuity and not to be a
cynic but I wonder if that next phase of
American ingenuity is like how do we
profit off of going to Mars yeah let's
talk about that Pepsi t-shirt American
market dude America Merck could put a
price tag on a rectangle we by Mercker
so if I can buy it so here's something I
would I ran the numbers on this you
could make a mission to Mars every time
on a lottery okay so we have 300 million
Americans yeah if everyone this is hard
but just I just running blunt numbers if
everyone puts in $100 okay that's a lot
for most people but just it's not an
unreachable amount of money we've all
spent a hundred dollars on something in
our lives before okay and we're puttin
hundred for the chance that you will be
on that mission mm-hmm and $100 times
300 million is what it's how much 30
this should not require a calculator
move the decimal over two places so it's
just 30 million mister math guy yeah
30 billion yeah dollars that is two
years of NASA's budget allocated by the
government the nth plus NASA puts in
some the government puts in some you
pull it dude this I think there's some
variant on that that that and you know
everyone will do it every week I mean
why not and if you don't get to go you
get to see other people go and that's
part of your pleasure yeah I bet you'll
get more pleasure watching someone else
walk on Mars and you would watching
someone else win the mega bucks lottery
I know I get always no pleasure from you
didn't I did yeah this is a good route
for somebody right right exactly
I think there is a way I think there's
financial ways in which you can make it
uh
a closer reality I think that what we
talked about earlier as well I think as
a country we have to care about this and
the things that often move us are fear I
think number one but yet fear is a
biggie
whether it's patriotic pride of
something that we can achieve I don't
know I think we could use some of that
there there is a sense of unity there
but I think like we like to compete and
I think seeing China land on the dark
side of Moon suddenly makes maybe us a
little bit more exciting far dude I
blew that one didn't I yeah cuz you know
yeah you know you know where I get dirty
could you take let's end the show now it
was going so well
it was both sides of the Moon gets
online you took you took a chance at
having to be a guest and the co-host
where do i fire our booking uh no no
I'll give you I give you a hall pass on
that one only because of how strongly
influential Pink Floyd's Dark Side of
the Moon album was thank you whether or
not that was your favorite albums you
should say it was your favorite that was
my favorite album see there it is for me
guys please yeah so I agree that if
China looks like some kind of frenemy
threat because obviously we trade
heavily with them so they're not an
explicit military and I mean we're not
aiming missiles at each other but the
idea that they would do something first
and we don't were Americans that that
could lie to ignite a flame under us so
um tell me about other topics that are
that we can look forward to well we are
our final episode that we're covering we
covered legalized marijuana in
California and so you know there's an
equity program out there that tries to
deal with basically people who are
affected by the war on drugs trying to
give them preferential treatment in
starting businesses in Oakland
California
oh nice okay so it's a drug show this is
a drugs yeah yeah yeah yeah so another
way to go to space if you will so that
so that drops up ten episodes how many
offers eight episodes eight episodes oh
yeah well we look forward to more of
this yeah we got out there I will be out
of fungi and maybe we can get you back
for just fix that Dark Side of the Moon
I'll do my research Neil that's on me I
promise to be better if you invite me
back I promise to be better excellent
dude thanks Neil thank you
this has been Startalk most of you have
heard the show some of you may have even
watched it on our YouTube channel I've
had Jordan Klepper our guest triple
serving as my co-host my expert and a
comedian and a informative guy and the
main interview and we don't do that
often and only when we've got it all
wrapped up into one character as he is
I'm Neil deGrasse Tyson as always
bidding you to keep looking up